right
okay
as i was saying i was
because when they were doing their tests
how many times
oh
you
foreign
foreign
good
uh
you
not
[Music]
great
[Music]
you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
and mrs trump
thank you very much please
those are friendly truckers they're on
our side
uh it's almost a celebration in a way
please sit down please
the first lady and i are thrilled to
welcome you
this afternoon for our second event
recognizing
extraordinary americans who have
responded to the invisible enemy we know
what the invisible
enemy is we've learned a lot with
exceptional bravery and commitment and
love and we appreciate it very much
great job fantastic job in the midst of
this
pandemic our nation has been united in
grief and in prayer
for the precious lives that have been
lost
we've also come together in awe in
admiration for the heroism and
patriotism that we're witnessing
all across our country here with us
today is
amy ford a nurse of 17 years
from williamson west virginia great
state where is
amy hi amy weeks ago after telling her
children she loved them
amy got in a plane for the first time in
her life and traveled to new york to
help
for the past 42 days she's been working
12-hour shifts
in the intensive care units of kings
county hospital center in brooklyn i
know it well
i know that building well i've passed it
many many times
and amy has been serving the coronavirus
patients around the clock she once held
the hand of an elderly patient all night
long
just so the woman would not feel alone
boy that's something thank you amy
that's incredible
i want to thank you for what you've done
what a great story i've heard about this
story
please come up and say a few words
please have me
that's great
hello um i want to thank you for having
me here today
um being able to serve our country as a
front-line worker during this pandemic
has truly been an honor i like you said
i've been in rm for 20 or for 17 years
under normal circumstances as a nurse i
would have an idea of a treatment plan
and unfortunately i was not afforded
that comfort in the beginning
of this pandemic these were not normal
circumstances
there were times of trial and error and
a whole lot of prayer
i had to adapt to a new way of nursing
one where treatment was still unknown
one where families had to trust my word
and i had to prove that my word was
trustworthy
one where i could only provide comfort
by holding my patient's hand
because i could no longer give comfort
with numbers and statistics
of success rates those were unavailable
in the beginning
i provided families comfort through
facetime calls
holding my phone up to a patient's ear
hoping
that by hearing their loved one's voice
it would in turn give them comfort as
well
this experience has been one of the most
emotionally challenging things that i've
ever been through
but it has made me a better person in
the end
there is a lot at the end of the tunnel
we are beginning to see
progress and we are starting to see
stories of success
this virus may have initially caught our
great nation off guard
but we will overcome this and we will
prevail
thank you amy did you ever catch the
virus did you ever
you never got it so with all of that
long hours and
with very very sick people you never
caught the virus
what do you attribute that to ppe
oh really good good protection so you
feel so you've had great protection
so you feel that if you have the
protection you won't catch it
you feel that i feel that's what's
protected me that is fantastic good
wow and i have not had any me personally
i have not had any shortage of ppe and
your co-workers
are they do that not at the hospital
that i'm at no that's incredible
so you all have very good equipment as
the expression goes right
the gowns and the masks everything thank
you very much amy
that's great amazing
it's a great story also with us is ben
ross the co-founder of a small custom
tie business called brackish bow ties in
charleston south carolina great place
ben is also with his team has shifted to
producing protective masks for
medical workers and he's done it
completely free of charge that's
fantastic as ben
says we've pushed the gas pedal down
and we haven't let up so brackish bow
ties
has donated more than 2 000 mass 31
medical facilities in 10 states
and ben's also been able to keep all 48
of his employees on the payroll
thanks to the paycheck protection
program great ben
could you come up and say a few words i
can tell it's you by the tie i assume
that's just that's the man i'm talking
about
thanks ben
thank you so much mr president it is
truly an honor to be here thank you ben
it is because of jeff plattner's guiding
hand the passion of the entire brackish
team
and the leadership of this country that
we are being recognized here today
i am humbled to be in this garden today
with such an amazing group
of individuals making such a difference
during these unprecedented times
congratulations to you all and thanks so
much for all you all are doing
i have no doubt that the united states
of america will soar above this
and come out stronger and more grateful
for family friends
community and this nation because we all
know we're all in this together
and only together we'll be able to curb
coronavirus
thank you thank you great job thank you
very much
fantastic and i like that tie very much
by the way
today we also honor sergeant spencer
garrett an officer with the
new york pd that's new york's finest
that's for sure right
who contracted the coronavirus after
four weeks of fighting a painful battle
against the virus spencer recovered and
immediately returned
to the front lines grateful for all of
the support of his family friends
colleagues and time
all of the people and the work he's done
sergeant garrett wanted to provide that
same kindness to others
and i know so many of the people on
members of new york's finest that we
love them and say hello to them
okay with the aid of his union spencer
has made
it his mission to support these fellow
new yorkers so
if you would i'd love to have you come
on up and say a few words thank you
good afternoon
first i'd like to start by thanking
president trump and the first lady for
their unwavering support of the nypd
thank you
as one of your hometown cops i thank you
for your leadership during these
uncertain times
on march 29th i tested positive for
covert 19.
breaking the news to my parents janet
and james
my brothers lee and sam and to my
eight-year-old daughter liana
was downright scary i saw the fear in
their eyes
i looked at my daughter and i assured
her that he wasn't going anywhere
after a vigorous one-month fight i
returned to duty in late april after the
experience with the virus
i felt compelled to help the residents
of the housing development side patrol
in east harlem new york
we are all in this fight together almost
6 000
uniformed and civilian members of the
nypd contracted coven 19.
unfortunately some of those members
didn't make it home to their loved ones
handing out n95 masks and engaging an
important dialogue
by educating the residents that not only
do not have support and access to ppe
hit close to home for me excuse me i'm
honored to be here
i'm honored to be an nypd sergeant and
most of all i'm honored to be an
american
god bless police officers first
responders and all the frontline workers
around the country
thank you so how was that you went
through that process
and it took quite a while it took longer
than you would have thought
it took almost four weeks sorry and what
was it just complications complications
um i'm an asthmatic so it was a little
more difficult
and uh took a little extra care but my
daughter was there for me she helped me
out a lot and she's my hero
that's fantastic thank you you're my
hero thank you thank you say hello to
everybody
thank you
great we're also joined by three
terrific girl scouts
lauren sarava and leila
of the girl scout troop 744 from
elkridge maryland along with their
troop leader megan langley thank you
very much that's great
that's really great these amazing 10
year olds have donated 100 boxes of girl
scout cookies
to local firefighters doctors and nurses
and have spent approximately 200
personalized cards
to healthcare workers all over and
they're going to do a lot more
their ambition is to do a lot more and i
think layla you're going to come up and
you're going to speak why don't you all
go up and stand and maybe lately you say
a few words that would be great thank
you very much
please
that's great thank you
hello my name is laila khan with troop
girl scout troop 744 i just wanted to
say
thank you mr president it is an honor to
have been invited to the white house
and it has been a very exciting day we'd
like to first thank you and your
staffers for ensuring our safety today
we appreciate all the safety measures
that were put into place
in the middle of march when everything
began to shut down we like many
americans
felt compelled to support our healthcare
and other essential workers and show
our appreciation we donated cases of
cookies to our local firehouses
and hospitals and we made cards to mail
to
hospitals in our community our troop has
a number of parents that are health care
workers so one of the parents
helped to take our personalized cards
and place them on the lockers of doctors
nurses and other essential workers
throughout
children's national hospital while we
are honored that the troop was invited
to be here today
we know we are just part of the millions
of other children out there
that are doing amazing things to support
their community
their friends and their family it is a
privilege to be here representing all of
them
they've made cards painted pictures held
virtual parties
and have demonstrated how we are all in
this together
our message is that everyone can do
something whether it is donating cookies
adjusting
to distance learning or help or just
helping out our parents
we have come together to support each
other during this uncertain time
thank you for the opportunity to serve
our community our essential workers and
our country
thank you very much thanks laila what a
great job thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
all three great job
also with us today is clay young a real
estate developer and landlord from
jonesboro arkansas
that's a fantastic place in march one of
clay small business tenants informed him
that they were concerned that they would
be unable to afford the rent
he immediately took the tenant's rent
check ripped it up and then waived
april's rent as well
clay had only one condition he said to
his tenant take care of your family and
pay your employees just take care of
those employees please
we'll get through this together and
that's what's happening clay then
told 11 more small business tenants that
he'd waived their rent payments as well
with the help of ppp loans many reopened
the doors
this week they just reopened so clay i
want to thank you very much
on behalf of all of us in this country
and if you come up and say a few words
that's a great thing
thank you clay
thank you mr president thank you so much
for having my wife pam and i here and
the first lady thank you it's truly an
honor i also want to say how proud i am
to be
part of a community and a great nation
that we've all gathered together to help
one another
through this trying time you know the
the work that i've done in my hometown
of jensboro arkansas the focus of that
has been on making my community better
as i saw what the virus was doing and i
saw what the virus would be doing to the
small business into
the employees of the small business i
realized that i needed to work with my
tenants
and for giving the rent it was the the
only option
and i remembered um thinking you don't
kick people when they're down
and over the last 20 years of being a
small business myself
and a developer and also a landlord
there's been tough times
and in those tough times i remember
those people
that came and they helped me and my
family and so in that moment
i thought this is my chance to maybe
just have some gratitude
and some humility and pay that forward
and i will always remember those people
so then after that we i helped my
tenants with the ppp loans
and i helped them help to participate in
this
amazing program that um
what has really served as an uh an
invaluable bridge for us all
and which brings us to where we are this
week so as we
work towards reopening the economy and
maybe returning our lives to some sense
of normalcy i just want to say thank you
so much again
for having me here today well i want to
say to you also and
being a landlord is a pretty good
business and i heard you've done really
well and it's nice what you've done clay
we appreciate it very much
thank you sir thank you say hello to the
people of your state your state is
wonderful
yes sir thank you i like it you know
that
thank you clay
so during this difficult time our
citizens are rising to the challenge
just as generations of americans have
done before us
america has never faced a trial like
this we've never had anything like this
happen
but we're going to endure and we're
going to thrive and we're going to do
better than ever before
the men and women we honor today remind
us that the bonds that unite us in times
of hardship
can also raise us to new heights as we
reopen
and recover and rebuild in the months
ahead we will harness our love and
all of the things that we hold so dear
to our heart
for our family for a community and for
the country
and will make america greater and
stronger than ever before and we're
going to transition into greatness we're
going to be seeing it and you're going
to be seeing it very soon
there's a pent-up demand and there's a
pent-up love and
there's so many things happening and
you're going to see the fruits of all of
the work that we've all been doing
working 24 hours
a day in some cases so i'd like to
thank everybody for being here
especially our
great great heroes because that's what
you are heroines and heroes
it's exactly what you are and i'd
like to ask these wonderful and
courageous americans to come forward
as i present them with a letter of
recognition
and i want to thank our first lady this
was a very important event for
first lady melania thank you very much
great job you're doing thank you
thank you honey okay please
amy ford
ben ross
sergeant spencer garrett
lauren matney
travia and a peretti
laila khan
clay young
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
bye